ukraine has been called the breadbasket
of the world producing along with russia
nearly a third of the world's wheat but
war there has brought exports to a
standstill and sent prices through the
roof
the war in ukraine is now adding a
frightening new dimension to this
picture of global hunger
russian russia's invasion of its
neighbor has effectively ended its food
exports
price increases of up to thirty percent
for staple food certain people in
countries across africa and the middle
east
including cameroon libya somali sudan
and yemen
covet and climate change are also blamed
for pushing more people into food and
security but the u.s called the meeting
of the u.n security council to highlight
the impact of conflict in particular the
ukrainian conflict on food prices and
they put the blame squarely on russia
the russian government seems to believe
that using food as a weapon
will help accomplish what its invasion
is not
to break the spirit of ukrainian people
still
ukrainians are going to great lengths to
feed their own people
and to feed the world the decision to
wage this war
is the kremlins
and the kremlins alone
if russia stopped fighting tomorrow
the war would end
if ukraine stopped fighting
there would be no more ukraine
russia pushed back blaming ukraine for
blocking ports and the west's economic
sanctions for price increases
but if you don't want to remove your
sanctions of choice then why are you
accusing us of causing this food crisis
why is it that as a result of your
irresponsible geopolitical gains the
poorest countries and regions should
suffer
the un secretary general has been trying
to negotiate a deal to reopen ukraine's
ports and revive russia's exports he
says right now there is enough food in
the world to feed everyone but the world
food program is warning that could
change if the war continues with the
number of hungry people in the world
expected to rise even further
kristen salumi al jazeera the united
nations